[Music]
the world is full of extraordinary
places but rarely do we experience them
come alive introducing the window a new
web series from Wired
[Music]
go deep underground New York City to the
country's largest transportation project
explored a robotics warehouse that's
changing the face of online commerce and
meet the people tackling these amazing
engineering challenges I don't think
they even know the labor and all the
love that goes into putting that cord
together that they plan on every night
the window is a peek into the vanguard
of 21st century industrial capability a
hypnotic and immersive journey to
spectacular spaces that reveal
humanity's quest for efficiency
innovation and ingenuity
join us on a mind-bending journey as we
take you where you're not allowed to go
and show you what you never knew existed